our last presentation for today is going
digital the whys and hows of adopting
digital pathology sponsored by Leica
biosystems and hosted by Dr Olga Colgan
Global brand strategy director at Leica
biosystems Dr Alexander Barris associate
director of pathology informatics at
Johns Hopkins medicine and Nathan
buckbinder VP of operations at prasia
Incorporated
my name is Marie and I will be your
moderator for today's event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the Q a
box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
please note that following this
presentation there will not be a live q
a session our digital pathology team
will be happy to welcome you and answer
any of your questions during our Social
Hour event in the San Francisco room at
6 PM EDT or 3 and 3 pm PDT there you
will have the opportunity to chat with
our subject matter expert and
participate in live product
demonstration
thank you and we look forward to seeing
you in the San Francisco room
um my name is Olga Colgan I am the
director of marketing for pathology
Imaging with Leica biosystems for emea
Europe Middle East and Africa and I'd
like to speak with you today about going
digital
um and the the wise and has of adopting
a digital pathology solution
so to have a little bit of a look back
before we look forward
um and to really have a look at the
evolution of digital pathology and it
would be remiss of me not to maybe take
a little bit of a step backwards and
look at Imaging in general so really it
was around the 1600s that we saw the
emergence of microscopy and then over
the next 300 years really saw huge
developments in the Imaging but staying
predominantly with the same modality of
a sample a light source and
magnification where your microscope your
sample and your reviewer in this case
the Pathologists all have to be in the
same place at the same time
then around the late 1900s we start
seeing the emergence of photomicrographs
being used giving some level of sharing
to to images and then really in the
1980s seeing the emergence of
some kind of tally pathology so being
able to remotely review slides in a live
view type scenario
um but it wasn't really until the turn
of the century that we start seeing the
emergence of whole slide Imaging and
really the birth of digital pathology
and in the the last 18 years we've
really seen a technological maturity
around digital pathology both in the the
digital pathology specific Solutions but
the hardware and the software
but also in the infrastructure and the
technologies that underpin
um a digital pathology deployment things
like the processor speeds and servers
that would be used the storage costs
associated with housing a whole slide
images as well as the the performance of
broadband and increased connectivity and
availability
and really this leads us to a situation
where digital pathology today really
incorporates all these elements of
scanning and management and sharing and
interpretation of pathology information
in a digital environment
then if we have a look at some of the
trends that we're seeing in pathology as
a whole
and we see a decline in practicing
Pathologists
um really at the moment it's happening
but
um predicted to worsen in coming years
where we have a lot of Pathologists
reaching retirement age and these are
not being backfilled at the same rate or
at the rate that we we need globally to
cover the pathologist's requirement and
it's forecasted that there'll be a net
deficit of almost 6 000 Pathologists
worldwide by 2030
and if we add to this the increasing and
ongoing demands on Pathologists and
pathology departments with the emergence
of new sub-specialties and over 25 of
them existing at the moment and the
emergence of things like new biomarkers
and new detection methods and really
we're faced with a situation where we're
being asked to do a lot more with a lot
less and we need to look at innovative
solutions to support that then if we
look at a pathology and well some of
these images are are kind of quite
extreme it is reflective of a lot of
pathology and anatomical pathology
departments who are using glass slides
where you see you've got your paper
files and your glass slides and for
you know large geographic regions
this can be a huge challenge where
you're faced with shipping slides around
between
um different experts in order to to read
and share the slides a shortage of
pathologists
um and then we see an increase in in
tests as well they say being driven by
new biomarkers and coupled with all of
this we have DNA
um fragile nature of glass slides which
really doesn't lend itself to to
packaging and shipping both from the
safety of the sample perspective but
then also from the the time and that
that will take to shift those slides
around
so hear it like a biosystems we look at
the whole pathology workflow and take a
holistic really system-wide view of
pathology looking at from the excision
of a biopsy under the piece of tissue
right through to reading of that slide
and all of the steps in between and look
at a fully integrated
approach on how do you enable control of
the whole Lab through integrated I.T
Solutions and and managing the different
steps throughout the whole process to
ensure a standardization and quality
and throughout the whole process and
ultimately delivering uh a perfect glass
slide which can then be digitized and
reviewed
when we look then at the reasons to to
go digital I say there are a lot of
pressing kind of Economic and and social
factors at play but I think for people
when they're choosing to go digital it
really is well what is the the use case
what is the problem you're looking to to
solve
um where digital pathology can really
support this is with things like um
being able to implement a fully digital
solution where you can open up your
laboratory information system and
actually review slides review your h e
review your IHC slides from your Lis
interface and eliminate the the need for
glass handling at that point and and
also to leverage rapid peer-to-peer
collaboration to receive input from
colleagues that when reviewing slides
and again to do that without having to
shift physically ship the glass around
between sites and between people and
we're a digital pathology you can really
come into play is removing that
necessity where
the slide the microscope and the
reviewer all need to be in the one place
at the one time
by leveraging digital pathology you have
that anytime anywhere access
to the the slides by the right person at
the right time
and it also helps not just for
peer-to-peer collaboration but also
outside or external collaboration so
expanding your field of experts that you
can call upon and really looking at this
and going how do you make it as easy to
use as possible
so I think there are a number of factors
or steps when going digital in pathology
or making that leap and
it can be quite transformational and
impact multiple departments within an
organization
so looking at some practical steps on
how to actually go digital I think that
the first big step is looking at finding
your Champion for digital pathology
um who is that person who really knows
what they they want to achieve and can
help drive that message and get buy-in
throughout the department
and then really looking at defining the
needs of your organization and the goals
that you're looking to to cover and set
those out as ideally quantifiable steps
that you're looking to cover
and then it's a case of looking at your
individual needs and every organization
every department is going to be
different and it's not a one-size all
approach or one size fits-all approach
where you really need to specify what
are the type of samples you're looking
at what are the needs what's the
infrastructure and that's required and
for things like integrating with an Lis
what does that look like and what are
your requirements is that an upfront
requirement is that something you add at
a later date
um then it's a case of building the
workflow and when building the the
workflow this is both looking at the the
physical side of things within the
laboratory and the the different steps
that are maybe brought into the lab
workflow eliminating the need for some
of the other physical steps so things
like
automated case sorting that can be done
leveraging barcodes
um so that all that the slides are
associated with one case are aggregated
together automatically which can help to
eliminate the physical glass sorting and
slide sorting that can be hugely time
consuming within a lab
so to really build that workflow let's
say both from the digital side of things
as well as the the physical
laboratory impact
and and then to roll out your
configuration and your your training
um on how again that system looks that's
unique and tailored to your organization
and then absolutely it's about to roll
out the adoption getting all your users
up and running and then looking at
analyzing the the benefits
of that use case and the going back to
the defining the needs and goals how
does your solution actually support your
initial premise and your goals that were
identified and then look to expand on
that and how do you grow the solution to
leverage it and most effectively and
expand on the applications
so as mentioned
this really isn't a
one-size-fits-all type scenario when
you're looking at adopting digital
pathology they're within Leica we
consider three main areas to consider
when looking at your solution and break
these into three categories of scan
manage and analyze
so when you're looking at scanning not
all scanners are the same and not all
needs of departments are the same so it
really is a case of considering what
type of samples is it that you're
looking to scan
are they all right field one by three h
e or our IHC slides
or do you do some fluorescence work
potentially some larger slides for
things like prostate samples
um or with the emergence of a lot of new
molecular biomarkers are fish slides
something that you would need to
consider and to look both at your
current throughput requirements
um the volume that you're looking to to
put through as well as future proofing
to an extent for what will your needs
look like within the next one three or
five years
um and then once you've defined what you
need from a scanning perspective that's
fabulous you can create whole slide
images
but really then the the key
consideration is how do you manage these
and it's about managing the the images
but also managing the associated
metadata that goes with these
integrating with the laboratory
information management system
so that you have automation of the
transfer of information between the two
systems eliminating the need for double
data entry and and also ensuring that
you eliminate that potential step for
error by having to to enter data into a
system
and really this system should be secure
and robust but also flexible enough to
manage your different images your
different levels of users who may need
access to the system and as well as that
also your your different deployment
options depending on your it
Department's preference and whether
you're looking at deploying for a single
site maybe on premise
or looking at networking together a
number of different sites and a hub and
spoke type deployment and or
alternatively leveraging Cloud
infrastructure and looking at
potentially a hosted solution so again
really tailoring the solution that's
specific to the needs of your department
and then as we look at analyze being
that third pillar to consider it's you
know about considering well are you
going to interpret these manually so on
screen analysis and manual analysis
where you can leverage things like the
um improved accuracy in doing
measurements on screen as opposed to to
trying to do them under a microscope
with a ruler and a marker and for things
like measuring margins or tumor size
or if you want to take it one step
further and start moving towards and the
automated image analysis side of things
where really you start to bring in a
level for biomarker interpretation where
you're bringing in a level of
reproducibility and quantitative
analysis that removes that inheritance
subjectivity that you have with manual
review and really gives you objective
quantifiable data
um so all of these things as I say are
all to be considered when looking at a
solution but also to consider that you
can start small and scale these things
up to really provide the optimal
solution for your department with that
um I'd like to thank you very much for
your attention and pass you over to Dr
Alex Barris who will continue from this
point
thank you very much
hi this is Alex varus
um thank you for the kind introduction
um I wanted to speak to you all a little
bit today about our experience in the
research and educational landscape
leveraging digital pathology one point
of clarification just in case others
were wondering there really are two
aspects when we talk about digital
pathology the first being whole slide
Imaging in which we take a slide whether
it was stained with h e or immune
histochemistry or other staining
techniques and construct a high
resolution image of the entire slide and
that is a static file that can be looked
at over and over and over again
an alternative version of digital
pathology uh is where we do live
microscopy in which a live feed is
coming off of a microscope and is
presented on different monitors be they
in the same office in the same building
in the same state or around the world
and the two have different
strengths and weaknesses primarily one
of the biggest ones to consider
have to do with the difference in the
time it takes to generate the digital
version of the slide with obviously the
live Imaging from the microscope being
nearly instantaneous and whole slide
Imaging requiring some amount of time to
prepare the digital version of the slide
distributed into some framework and then
be able to analyze it
for for us uh the biggest use cases in
the context of this presentation have
been in uh Education and Research along
with the ability to generate high
quality publication level images from
our repositories along with various use
cases for telepathology and internal
conferences at Johns Hopkins
just as a brief overview of the hardware
and software stack that one should be
considering when implementing digital
pathology really it starts with
obviously some type of Hardware that's
going to take this slide or
alternatively there are some
technologies that are being considered
that actually scan directly the tissue
nonetheless there's some Hardware that
has to take the physical material and
convert it to a digital image and some
of the criteria that you'll want to look
at for conventional whole Supply Imaging
modalities include how it handles the
slides what kind of Optics it uses to
visualize those slides and what kind of
detectors it has and that set of that
set of the of the technology stack here
basically is the hardware component but
there still is going to be some software
that sits on top of that within the
scanner to stitch together the different
high resolution patches that are taken
of the image and eventually compress the
data into a manageable format and be
able to represent the whole slide image
some of the more commonly used whole
slide Imaging formats and then from that
point you'll want to consider what types
of viewers and analytics you'll want to
layer on top of that starting with basic
criteria like what your repository is
going to look like is it going to be a
network attached storage device within
your institutions infrastructure will
you be looking for cloud storage and
then what how will you visualize the
slides will it be a local application on
someone's computer will it be a
web-based viewer and what implications
does it have for how well you can share
and analyze your data this is just a
brief overview of what the hardware and
software technology stack looks like in
in and they're different factors that I
think are reviewed there briefly of what
what you have to consider for each of
these pieces it's important to think
about how the slides are generally these
whole slide Imaging formats are
generally stored in a manner that mimics
the way we think about
visualizing slides on the microscope
with different objectives representing
different magnifications of the whole
image so our overarching goal is to for
the research education at Hopkins is to
provide a simple web-based resource for
viewing annotating whole slides we want
to Foster collaboration both in within
Hopkins walls along with our
collaborators around the world we want
to lay the framework down for a common
infrastructure that will enable
analytics on these slides because that's
the promise that digital pathology
allows is not just to visualize and
interpret them by the same mechanisms we
do to on the microscope but actually to
enable analytics
image analysis routines and the like to
generate more data from these slides
than we previously could and also we are
proponents of Open Source algorithms in
the context of these analyzes as a
analogy
in my experience over the last couple
decades in bioinformatics I think that
was probably one of the biggest pushes
around 2000 ish to
start opening up the uh the algorithms
that process bioinformatic data into the
academic community so they could really
be refined and perfected and that fueled
a whole library of tools like
bioconductor in the r language and I
suspect similar things are I mean are
occurring now and digital pathology and
will continue to occur and will Propel
the field forward
um our research and educational
web-based platform that I alluded to
previously is available at the website
you can see here and I invite you all to
come visit
um you can log in as a guest you can
also register an account within our
system so that there's some more
capabilities that you'll be able to do
and our internal Hopkins staff also has
a dedicated login where they can come in
and upload slides the ability to
annotate cases starts with the concept
of repositories so in order to enable
our researchers to do this each
repository within this framework has its
own set of attributes that each project
might be might be relevant to so for
example one repository a repository is
represented here by one of these tabs
for example where it says pancreas in
the in the slide that's being shown may
have certain attributes that relate to
pancreas cases that are relevant however
other repositories might be combinations
of tmas like the one labeled tma-833 and
we may need to have different sets of
attributes that we'll want to be able to
annotate these slides with
as you can see here
we have a variety of different cases
that are represented in these TMA
formats and that's a natural place where
a lot of these analytics are being
applied because it's a quick way to have
a lot of different cases represented on
the same slide and being stained with
different markers and these are active
areas of research that various
investigators or Hopkins are using
actually the platform that you're seeing
here to to answer very interesting
questions
we also have for education the
well-known Johns Hopkins surgical
pathology unknowns case conference
Series this is an example of a public
repository as opposed to what I was
showing you previously were internal
repositories that can be shared with you
know collaborators and the like but this
is one that you can that you can access
uh directly without having to log in it
represents a collection I think of
nearly 2 000 cases each week at Hopkins
week collect uh maybe a you know five to
ten interesting cases from the cases
that were presented uh that way that we
saw that were encountered that week we
annotate them with what the diagnosis is
and then the residents prepare their
thoughts on them and to discuss it with
attending each week and you can see the
attending's name and the date of the
conference and we have had this as a
public conference for many many years
but the ability to share it with the
world the last few years has been very
exciting for us
um and when we go to our pathology
meetings I always am excited to hear
that colleagues of mine find it very
valuable to review these cases both
spanning residency level folks and
attendings as well while it does serve
as a educational piece to be able to
show these materials in some sense it
might also be an interesting case
collection from a research and analytic
perspective because these are relatively
rare or more interesting diagnoses and
so if machine learning techniques would
want to look at these and and
potentially try to develop some
algorithms off of it it would be an
interesting substrate to look at I
mentioned briefly uh that I were very
interested in having a framework for
analytics and this platform does enable
that we're working closely with our
technology Partners on this to enable
effectively an API to access annotated
slides for folks who want to dive a
little bit deeper into these images and
the data behind them
so in terms of what we're thinking about
at Hopkins for uh various degrees of
difficulty if you will in the analytics
space I think the most interesting and
probably probably most applicable is to
really refine our ability to do a
quantitation of the immunohistic
chemistry in particular some of the more
routine
um but you know biomarkers again even
though I've had a significant experience
in in bioinformatics which I guess most
the time people think about genomics
proteins are still molecules so this is
still molecular Diagnostics right and
there's a critical piece of interpreting
these tumors so some of the common
quantitative biomarkers that we look at
today are listed there including Erp R
Ki her2 and pdl1 which has been a big
important thing in the immuncology space
so I consider these very low hanging
fruits because
um
it's something that we should be able to
do a good job with or already a lot of
algorithms that are out there that have
promising results and we look to try and
you know do large-scale validations to
get these off the ground
um moving to more
um more more ripe fruits I guess our
various deep learnings deep learning
approaches in imaging we this example
here is a project that my team had
worked on for the breast cancer
challenge the bach challenge recently
that was I think closed out earlier this
year using deep convolutional neural
networks to distinguish benign from
malignant breast cancer and I think
these techniques really hold a lot of
Promise in particular towards the notion
of developing screening Technologies a
concept that is definitely not foreign
in pathology there are a variety of
things already in place in in pathology
that screen materials both at the as in
from a workflow perspective humans
screening slides for Pathologists or
machines so I think that this holds a
lot of promise to make our to make
Pathologists very efficient
and then more exotic fruits that I think
are coming down the pike in the next few
years such as uh there are various
Multiplex
multi-channel approaches and um
looking at both in the immuno
fluorescence along with conventional
light microscopy approaches to Multiplex
or have multi-channels of
biomarkers on the same slide and that
has a that has a corollary to our
ability to save precious biopsy tissues
if we can only have to use One mic one
five Micron section for the three or
four biomarkers that we need at the
immunistochemical level it saves
material for other
[Music]
um
uh um analyzes that have to be performed
um and then some new fruits that I think
um are not yet ready but we should be
considering and the concept is different
techniques that have been published on
recently such as this example on
pictographic microscopy in which we move
away from conventional bright field
intensity-based Imaging of these slides
and consider other modalities that allow
us to render a digital image but with
potentially more information than just
what we can can generate from uh bright
field microscopy
um so this kind of brings us into the
into the regime of computational
pathology where we want to focus on you
know numerous quantitative needs are
present in in in the molecular era even
if you're just talking about
immunistochemistry
um there's definitely a lot of novelty
in the Single Cell parametric space so
the notion of being able to do something
like flow cytometry but in situ which
means that you're going to now have the
ability to analyze both the parameters
of the cell along with its location and
that's becoming an interesting Concept
in immuno oncology as well in this in
the sense that what type of immune cells
are present and where are they relative
to the tumor cells and then the not the
the thing I mentioned previously which
is the novelty in the way with which we
digitally capture these slides um and
how do we how can we go beyond light the
conventional light microscope
um
so in summary I think uh any informatics
talks a try if possible to end with an
acronym so uh when considering
um your infrastructure needs try to be
Savvy think about scanners analytics
viewers and informatics needs and for
research applications
um we focused on our ability to help our
residents with didactics along with
attendings throughout the world be able
to generate a framework that people can
layer annotations atop of digital
pathology and an API for analytics with
a focus on as I mentioned open source
for the actual algorithm development
piece
um I thank you all for your time
um and uh we can hold questions I think
till the end
thank you Dr Barris I'm Nathan
bookbinder I'm a co-founder and the Vice
President of Operations at prosha at
digital pathology Ai and software
company and I'd like to do three things
in the next 10 to 15 minutes first I'd
like to provide a quick overview of who
Prussia is and what we offer second I'd
hope to provide you with a fresh
perspective on some of the common
challenges and traditional barriers to
going digital and how we've seen our
customers overcome them and then third
I'd like to talk about why I personally
am so excited about the future of
digital pathology and pathology in
general and that's computational
pathology and and AI
Prussia is a digital pathology
artificial intelligence and software
company
we know that pathology is going digital
and approach is taking it there so we
build products that enable Pathologists
to effortlessly effortlessly transition
from their traditional microscope
workflow to the digital world through an
industry leading digital pathology
software platform with modules for
collaboration image analysis and
artificial intelligence
and by bringing together that
award-winning cloud and on-premises
workflow software and pioneering work in
artificial intelligence crochet provides
a simple flexible modular and
future-proof software platform for
pathology labs to go digital
so very briefly and at a high level I'd
like to quickly run through some of what
our customers do on our platform
the first broad set of functionality
relates to our data management and
workflow management uh platforms so we
have two broad operating systems
the first is repository oriented and it
enables you to store manage organize
and otherwise work with large
collections of whole slide images and
data and then the second is a workflow
oriented operating system which allows
our users and our adopters to start with
a case or with many cases and then move
them through
a customer defined digital set of
processes
for the second set of use cases that we
find our customers leveraging our
platform for relates to collaboration
and whether that's through
case assignments or real-time
telepathology with large groups or in a
smaller group setting for research for
inter-institutional reviews all of that
happens on that same base platform on
cloud or on-premises
and then broadly speaking the third set
of functionality and features pertains
to digital IHC
prosha offers a suite of research use
only staying specific algorithms that
Aid in producing consistent assessment
of IHC and H E stain slides
so like I mentioned prosha is a software
only company and we believe that while
the digitization of these whole side
images in and of itself is of course
necessary and useful the real value
comes in what software enables you to do
with those whole slide images so that
was a 30 000 foot view of the company
and our offerings and if you have any
questions about that I'd be happy to
address them uh in our q a portion or
afterwards so I encourage you to reach
out
now I'd like to jump into some of the
expectations challenges and
considerations that you as a potential
adopter or early adopter of digital
pathology might have as you go digital
so when Olga started this presentation
she gave a great overview of the history
of pathology and the evolution of
digital pathology but I'd like to focus
on some of the big changes that have
happened in the past couple of years
and there's really two big changes the
first is that Computing technology
including Cloud technologies have
advanced tremendously and really made
their way into organizations and this
radical shift has enabled new advances
in the technology new advances in the
use cases that are provided and in the
user experience and at the same time
these advancements have driven down the
cost of going digital
the second major shift is not really a
shift so much as increased pressure both
on the one hand to drive Revenue to see
more cases to do more with those cases
and at the same time to reduce costs
but one thing that's remained constant
throughout the entire digital pathology
history is that
you as the customer and consumer and end
user of digital pathology are in the
driving seat
so from my perspective one thing that
you should never concede on is that
digital pathology systems must conform
to your imagined and ideal workflow and
not the other way around
so diving a bit deeper into that your
organization your institution your
pathology group should be thinking about
a wide range of requirements and I'm
sure that those are coming from your I.T
staff from your legal department from
purchasing from your Pathologists and
histo technologists as well and this
wide range of requirements can broadly
be summed up into three basic questions
first does this work with what I'm
already doing
again whether that's from a pathology
management or an I.T perspective
the second question is will this product
serve me well today and tomorrow
essentially is this built to last and
then the third is this able to do
everything that I wanted to everything
that I need it to
and from our Vantage points at prosha we
see those as requirements concerning
Simplicity flexibility scalability
modularity and then of course building a
future-proof product
so of course adopting digital pathology
can sound quite intimidating and it
really doesn't have to be that way
approach we focus on a few things to
make going digital a bit simpler and
easier and less intimidating the first
is by ensuring that we provide a
flexible and scalable uh award-winning
cloud and on-premise platform again this
is something that has to be secure it
has to be compliant it has to be well
managed with the right user permissions
and user settings controls but the
flexibility ensures that IT addresses
the needs of your organization the
second thing that we do is provide use
cases that can be added modularly and
plug in directly into your existing
platform as needed so rarely is it a
good idea to go digital 100 so to go
from zero to completely digital in one
swoop
we find that that tends to cause a lot
of frustration for everyone working at
your institution and for the vendors
themselves and a modular adoption allows
you to start small start with use cases
that you know are very real very
concrete and could really benefit from
digital and then scale from there
and then the third thing that we do is
we make sure that we take the complexity
of implementation training and actually
using the digital pathology system out
of the hands of the pathologist so
if digital pathology is going to be
adopted it has to be usable by the
Pathologists and not just by
technologists or technology oriented
individuals
for the last couple of minutes what I'd
like to do is talk about what really
gets me excited about digital pathology
and that's computational pathology in
digital pathology and artificial
intelligence
now
I'm sure that you've heard at least
something in the past before this
discussion about computational pathology
and AI
and while I'm sure that there's a
thousand variations on the theme of what
those two concepts mean what it really
boils down to is taking the powerful
advances in technology and applying them
in a way that enables Pathologists in
Labs so that's a quick uh specific
example I'd like to point to some of the
work that approaches R D team recently
announced concerning it's a matter of
pathology
and what you see here is a visualization
of an ai-powered algorithm that was
trained to be able to identify tumor
regions on a whole slide image
now while this Remains the research use
only technology that still is in
development today AI powered technology
like this
when plugged into a digital pathology
operating system like process or others
and when applied appropriately to a
workflow has the potential to elevate
the economics and science of laboratory
medicine and ultimately put powerful
technology in the hands of pathologists